alors ce soir je vais vous parler de la
représentation des conflits et du regard
que je peux porter sur ces questions en
tant qu'artiste pour commencer je
voudrais commencer avec un projet que
j'ai réalisé en ukraine on février 2014
pendant la révolution
donc au début quand les événements ont
commencé j'étais à paris
et puis quand j'ai vu que le
gouvernement commençait à tirer sur les
manifestants comme tout le monde j'ai
été choqué donc j'ai commencé à faire
pas mal de recherches sur internet pour
essayer de mieux comprendre ce qui se
passait et puis je me suis aperçu que
entre les médias pro russe et les médias
pro occidentaux il y avait des analyses
totalement divergentes
du coup j'ai décidé d'aller là-bas de
voir véritablement ce qui se passait
éventuellement d'en témoigner et en fait
je suis arrivé le jour précisément où
ianoukovitch a fui location en laye
avait plus président du gouvernement
plus polis le pays était entièrement
sous le contrôle de la population et
c'est ce moment de latence ou vraiment
tout paraissait possible que j'ai voulu
capturer
à travers ce un portrait de ces
manifestants et avant les prendre en
photo je leur ai donné un questionnaire
où je leur ai demandé qu'est ce que vous
aimeriez qu'il se passe maintenant
et qu'est ce que vous pensez qu'il va se
passer donc l'idée du portrait est là
pour capturer l'individu l'intensité du
regard de chacun des manifestants le
questionnaire pour capturer leurs
craintes leurs espoirs
et puis avec ses récents portraits j'ai
décidé de faire un livre un livre que
j'ai fait imprimer sur du papier journal
l'idée étant de faire référence aux
médias si ce n'est que là c'est
directement ces manifestants qui ont la
parole et avec mon éditeur
on a décidé de transformer ce livre en
exposition c'est à dire qu'on peut
facilement retirer les pages du livre et
ensuite les coller pour sur les murs
pour chacun puisse faire sa propre
exposition
projet et six mois après la révolution
je suis retourné en ukraine
cette fois ci dans la partie est dans le
bon basse dans la région de donetsk et
j'étais collé ses portraits ces
questionnaires dont manière à ce que les
gens qui sont sous influence de la
propagande russe voit véritablement qui
étaient les personnes de maidan si j'ai
décidé de commencer avec ce projet c'est
parce que malgré l'aspect très brutes
c'est-à-dire portrait questionnaire
ce projet c'est des mises en scène comme
vous pouvez voir et en fin de compte la
mise en scène c'est un tabou dans la
photographie de guerre
quand on pense mise en scène on pense
manipulation trucage mensonge
or avec ce projet je pense que je dis
plus de choses sur ce qu'était maidan
qu'une série de photographies avec des
gens sur les barricades un cocktail
molotov à la main ou des pneus un train
de brûler et d'ailleurs de la croix
disait assez justement à ce propos
l'exactitude ne fait pas la vérité et on
va voir que tous les débuts de la
photographie de guerre
les photographes ne vont pas hésité à
transformer l'image à la manipuler pour
donner à voir l'image que eux avaient en
tête donc là vous avez une photographie
de la guerre de crimée 1853 et vous
voyez ici cette partie qui a été en
partie
apporte y changer et puis un peu plus
tard on va passer à une photographie de
brady pendant la guerre de sécession
donc brady en fin de compte
photographier beaucoup de cadavres après
les batailles il va pas hésité à
déplacer ses cadavres pour construire
une image une image extrêmement
picturales comme vous pouvez voir ici on
voit vraiment cette référence à la
peinture
et puis on s'aperçoit que il ya beaucoup
de l'image de guerre qui sont devenus
des icônes
quand j des icônes c'est à dire qu'à
elles seules elles deviennent la
représentation de ce conflit et il ya
énormément de ces images qui sont des
mises en scène ou du moins qui sont
suspectés des mises en scène quand je
dis suspecté je pense à cette fameuse
photo de robert capa du soldat fauché
par la balle ou alors d'autres qui sont
clairement des mises en scène comme le
drapeau américain sur la colline après
la bataille d'iwo jima
ou alors le drapeau soviétique sur le
reichstag
et puis même plus proche de nous quelles
sont les images les plus connus du grand
public de la guerre en irak
ça va être la chute de la statue de
saddam hussein qui est une mise en scène
qui a été orchestrée par l'armée
américaine
ça va être ces images absolument
horrible de la prison d'abou ghraib ou
là encore on est dans des mises en scène
et puis ces images de la capture de
saddam hussein avec un saddam hussein
chevelu barbu est un type qui regarde sa
bouche et en fin de compte dans ces
images donc on est temps de la mise en
scène et donc il ya véritablement un
questionnement ici qui m'intéresse sur
le réel sur la construction de l'image
de guerre la théâtralisation du conflit
et ça nous amène à un projet que j'ai
réalisés en irak en 2011 et 2012 qui
s'appelle théâtre de guerre où j'ai
travaillé avec de vrais combattants
sur de vraies zones de guerre donc ici
on est un groupe de guérilla kurde et
j'ai invité ses combattants à rejouer
leur réalité dans des mises en scène
inspirée de peinture classique voilà
et en fin de compte l'idée de reprendre
des mises en scène de peinture classique
c'était parce que dans la gestuelle de
la peinture
l'attitude est beaucoup plus maniéré et
donc du coup c'est ce côté très maniéré
qu'on va avoir dans ses photographies
qui vont trahir le dispositif de mise en
scène du coup lorsque le spectateur se
retrouve face à l'image
il va dire mais il ya un truc de est un
truc de fou dans cette image et puis il
va regarder le cartel il va voir qu'on
avec des vrais combattants sur une vraie
zone de guerre mais alors du coup quelle
est la part du réel
qu'est ce qui est vrai qu est ce qu'il
faut dans ces images et c'est ça qui
m'intéresse c'est vraiment ce doute
entre réel et fiction est d'ailleurs sur
ce questionnement entre réel et fiction
j'essayais d'en aborder on va dire un
autre une autre approche
une confusion qui peut avoir entre réel
et fiction entre la fiction du jeu vidéo
et le réel de la guerre je me suis
beaucoup intéressé à comment est-ce
qu'on va passer de ce jeu le jeu vidéo à
la guerre lorsque j'étais en colombie en
2006 j'étais à 50 kilomètres après la
ligne de front dans un village qui
étaient contrôlés par la guérilla des
farc est dans une halle je suis tombé
sur des gamins qui avait 12 13 ans et
qui était en train de jouer à un jeu
vidéo du type counter strike vous voyez
ces jeux vidéo en caméra subjective ce
qu'on appelle first person shooter où
vous tenez une arme comme ça et vous
êtes dans la peau d'un combattant et
depuis ce village on entendait
régulièrement des tirs parfois des
explosions et donc ces gamins ils
étaient au coeur du conflit
et pourtant leur premier perception du
combat aura été à travers le jeu vidéo
c'est quelque chose qui m'a profondément
marqué
et donc j'ai décidé de me pencher un peu
plus sur le sujet et je me suis aperçu
que pas mal de forces armées développer
leur propre jeu vidéo alors vous avez un
jeu vidéo ici développé par l'armée
américaine
régulièrement vous avez des liens sur le
site go army points comme le site de
recrutement de l'armée américaine et
puis il ya également des groupes de
guérilla qui développent leurs propres
jeux vidéo alors qu'alain qui est
particulièrement intéressant c'est le
jeu vidéo qui a été développé par le
hezbollah sur la guerre de 2006 entre
israël et le hezbollah et vous êtes dans
la peau d'un combattant vous jouez des
événements qui sont véritablement
déroulé et puis après chaque niveau vous
avez des images d archives qui ont été
filmées par les combattants à ce moment
là qui vous montre comment s'est
véritablement dérouler le jeu vous venez
de faire à quel moment vous sortez de la
fiction du jeu pour rentrer dans le réel
de l'arche yves et puis après vous avez
les simulateurs utilisés par les forces
armées pour s'entraîner ou donc là ils
mettent des capteurs sur leurs armes les
vraies armes ils vont tirer sur un écran
et puis après vous retrouver sur la zone
de guerre
alors là par exemple vous êtes en syrie
donc c'est un véhicule qui a été
développé par les rebelles est donc là
c'est un véhicule qui est équipé de
trois caméras à l'avant une caméra sur
la mitrailleuse et donc voilà le poste
de contrôle de la mitrailleuse donc vous
pouvez actionner la mitrailleuse est
tiré avec une manette de playstation
et puis
enfin vous avez les drones et donc qu'on
a des pilotes de drones qui sont dans
des zones sécurisées qui vont aller
bombarder en irak au pakistan en
afghanistan et c est en fin de compte
ici le réel prend toutes les formes de
la fiction toutes les formes du jeu
pourtant on est bien dans du réel et
d'ailleurs il ya certains pilotes de
drones qui n'ont jamais quitté les états
unis qui se retrouvent avec des poètes
des traumatismes post conflit donc sur
cette question des relations entre jeux
vidéo les zones de guerre je veux
présenter une vidéo
donc j'ai réalisé en 2007 et dans cette
dans cette vidéo donc c'est une
installation vidéo on a un couloir à ces
trois et que la vidéo qui est projeté au
fond dans cette vidéo tout est réel
lorsque le spectateur va rentrer dans
l'installation il sait que tout est réel
on est avec une vraie personne une vraie
arme dans des vrais souterrain et en fin
de compte le spectateur va rapidement
s'identifier aux personnages et il va
attendre le moment où un ennemi va
surgir il va voir le shoot
sauf que dans cette vidéo il ya une
tension permanente
mais il se passe rien il ya aucun shoot
est en fait généralement au bout de dix
quinze vingt minutes pour les plus
persistants le regard d'un repart
frustré de ne pas avoir vu le shoot et
en fin de compte ce qui m'intéresse
c'est cette frustration de voir à quel
point la la fiction interfère sur notre
appréhension des choses que en fin de
compte
face au réel ce qu'on attend c'est la
fiction
et puis cette vidéo prend une autre
dimension aujourd'hui puisque lorsque je
les réalise en 2007 j'ai filmée avec un
téléphone portable pour augmenter pour
renforcer l'idée du réel et en fin de
compte ça va préfigurer ce qu'on va voir
arriver quelques années plus tard à
partir de 2010 qui est l'utilisation des
téléphones portables par les combattants
qui vont eux-mêmes produire l'image du
conflit
or ce phénomène la pose de vraies
questions
les médias attendent du conflit les
représentations qu'ils attendent du
conflit ça va être
l'action l'événement or à partir du
moment où les combattants produisent de
l'image les combattrons ce qu'ont
toujours beaucoup plus proche de
l'action que les reporters puisque les
combattants sont eux mêmes acteurs de
l'événement alors que les reporters en
sont le témoin il ya une image
extrêmement symptomatique de ce
phénomène là c'est la première image qui
a été diffusée dans les médias de la
capture de fille de kadhafi
cette image a été faite par un
photographe de l afp philippe desmazes
est en fait il a photographié l'écran du
téléphone portable d'un combattant
tout simplement parce que il n'y avait
pas de reporter à ce moment là mais par
contre les combattants étaient là et
cette question de petits produits
l'image aujourd'hui on va y venir avec
un autre projet que j'ai réalisé un
projet vidéo
là encore ce projet
ces 24 heures de la vie d'un combattant
rebelle en syrie c'est un projet que
j'ai fait en août 2012
donc c'est avec l' armée syrienne libre
dans la région d'alep et d'idleb et en
fait ici j'ai fixé une caméra sur le
torse du combattant
ici c'est pas moi qui produit l'image
ici c'est le combattant qui produit
cette image et puis d'autres questions
que j'ai voulu soulever
à travers ce projet c'est la question de
la représentation qu'on peut avoir du
conflit dans nos sociétés occidentales
en effet si on regarde nos sociétés
occidentales le conflit extrêmement
présent que ça soit à travers les médias
où on a une image qui est basé
essentiellement sur l'événement le tir
l'explosion le corps sans vie
que ça soit dans les films ou sur 1h30
de film vous allez avoir une heure de
combat une demi heure de scènes d'amour
et puis après vous avez les jeux vidéo
ou là on tire on tire on tire sans arrêt
et donc on s'aperçoit que le conflit
extrêmement présent dans nos sociétés et
l'image qu'on en a est extrêmement
fantasmée et dans ce projet donc c'est
un plan séquence de 24 heures qui est
diffusée après en temps réel c'est à
dire que lorsque le regardeur via un 9
heures du matin il est 9 heures du matin
pour le combattant lorsqu'il vient à
deux heures l'après midi les deux heures
l'après-midi pour le combattant donc on
vit véritablement la vie de ce
combattant en temps réel et en fin de
compte la réalité du conflit c'est quoi
ce avant tout la tente on attend on
attend en fin de compte
cette vidéo montre justement cette
attente avec une tension permanente
puisqu'on sait jamais si on serait
encore vivant à la fin de la journée est
donc cette vidéo est très souvent
extrêmement ennuyeuse alors parfois on
voit le combattant qui se promènent en
mobylette parfois leaders alors on voit
le plafond pendant une heure puis après
ils se retourner sur levante on entend
ronfler pendant 20 minutes après ils
regardent un sitcom égyptien la télé il
fait des blagues avec ses amis nettoie
son arme pendant plus de deux heures
donc voilà on voit vraiment cette
réalité du conflit en dehors de tout
fantasme et puis face à ces différents
phénomènes que j'ai abordé la question
du fait que les combattants produisent
eux-mêmes de l'image face au fait que
les médias veulent des images de plus en
plus fraîches
ils veulent de l'instantané et puis face
au fait que les reporters aujourd'hui
sont devenus de véritables cibles
c'est presque plus dangereux sur zone de
guerre d'être à reporter que d'être un
combattant et donc face à ces différents
phénomènes on peut se demander si
l'avenir de la représentation des
conflits aussi terrible soit il ça va
pas être une sorte de télé réalité de la
guerre qui serait filmé par des drones
ou en fin de compte on pourrait vivre
une sorte de guerre derrière notre écran
à travers un peu la peau du combattant
en live une sorte de guerre par
procuration
et pour finir j'aimerais aborder une
dernière question autour de la
représentation des conflits une
représentation qui n'est pas basé sur
l'instantané mais qui s'inscrit dans la
mémoire cette représentation je voudrais
vous en parlait à travers un projet que
j'ai réalisés en irak que j'ai réalisés
en 2010 et en fait à ce moment là donc
j'étais logé sur le campus de
l'université de sanaa dean et quelques
jours après mon arrivée
un des étudiants a été kidnappé juste
devant l'université j'étais seul
occidental dans l'université à ce moment
là et donc du coup il ya pas mal de ses
amis qui sont venus voir qu'ils m'ont
pris à témoin et qui m'ont dit oui
regarde sardasht donc sert d'acheter le
nom de cet étudiant qui a été kidnappée
c'est lui que vous voyez ici regarde
sardasht écrivait pas mal d'articles oui
dénoncé la corruption et la cooptation
dans le pouvoir local et du coup ils ont
kidnappé
ils m'ont montré notamment le dernier
article qu'il a écrit qui s'appelle
j'entends sonner les cloches de ma mort
dans cet article il explique qu'il a
reçu des menaces de mort que s'ils
continuent d'écrire il sera exécuté
et il explique qu'il va pas fuir il va
rester et qu'il est prêt à mourir et
qu'il espère que sa mort aidera défendre
ses idées
et quelques jours plus tard
effectivement on a retrouvé son corps
ils avaient été exécutés et donc j'ai
voulu rendre hommage et pour lui rendre
hommage en fait donc j'ai pas mal
travaillé avec ses amis avec sa famille
qui m'ont donné une photo de lui donc
c'est cette photo que vous voyez là et
puis je suis rentré en france avec cette
photo j'en ai fait des tirages papier
salé donc le papier salé c'est une
vieille technique du 19e siècle des
tirages que j'ai pas fixé que j'ai
enfermé dans une boîte noire et un ans
après sa mort je suis retourné en irak
et pour le 1er anniversaire donc de
cette mort j'ai été très tôt le matin
dans les rues quand il faisait encore
nuit
cole et son portrait de manière à ce que
quand les gens sont sortis ils tombent
nez à nez avec son portrait avec ce
portrait de sardanes et puis quand le
soleil a commencé à se lever
progressivement le portrait s'est mis à
disparaître pour laisser place à un
rectangle noir
je remercie de votre attention